sau ở các bạn khác, không phải ra.
Này ở chuyển ở đây,
cái này rất là tả nó,
đúng không?
Này bị rụ, đều đều tên.
Này ở đây,
đúng không?
Các cánh tử hả lâu đến phố xí mình.
Để không phải ra,
nó bàn đầu xí mình bà ở hả lâu.
Lúc sau,
đúng không?
Sau khi có cánh ở đây rất là phố xí mình.
Đúng không?
Thế nó sẽ xí chuyển từ hả lâu đến phố xí mình.
Để đây là đoạn làm gì chuyển ở đâu?
Đúng không?
Ô tôn làm mạnh trên đường của như vậy?
Để không?
Viet có mà,
đi bộ,
đến trường mà,
ở đây không?
Quảng cánh tử nhà đến trường mà,
các bạn có bắt đầu đi bộ.
Tử nhà các bạn,
đến trường mà,
đúng không?
Để không là sự thay đổi vị trí.
Nó,
bắt đầu qua đang ở nhà,
nó có xóa đổi trường mà.
Để là sự thay đổi vị trí của
bắt này sau,
đúng không?
Bắt thông thường như cái xin trọng,
cái bắt làm mộ.
Để trường mà,
Các bạn để trọng nhà các bạn làm mộ?
Đúng không?
Các bạn để trọng,
bến tầu làm mộ?
Đúng không?
Có,
bắt đầu qua,
cái này có là chuyển nập cơ.
Nó khác với mộ khá nhiệm mà sau
để lắm ở mộ cho họ,
có là sao được cơ.
Nếu chuyển nập cơ,
thì đúng là gản nộ,
nó sẽ thay đổi vị trí của bắt này.
Sau với đúng khác,
nó sẽ có là những chuyển nập
thông thường hàng ngày in trụ ba đấy.
Ok, trên nào,
hãy mày sẽ nhá.
Bắt nào mà chưa bà pho lâu,
chưa xa pho ai thời,
như thế,
thì mà xa pho ai,
thì còn xem là,
bù họng này không hai không như là
nhận cái phi,
bài liệu này,
trên thế nào,
một thái niệm nữa,
khả năng cao lần,
thì lớp,
cũng ít thay gú tệ các bạn,
nhưng mà thay vị lệm các bạn,
thì còn nhiều điều này.
Bỏ là khái niệm với chất biểu.
Bởi vì chất biểu.
Khái niệm với chất biểu.
Khái niệm này thì làm một khái niệm
xưa khái niệm của chuyển nộ.
Thì các bạn cần phải nắm nửng.
Bỏ,
hãy xong còn liệu,
là có đó là chất biểu này.
Bởi vì xong là 2 loi câu là chất biểu này.
Chất biểu này,
là chất biểu này.
là những vật khóc kích thức rất nhỏ.
Sau bị quán đường đi được.
Qua quán cách mà chúng ta để cập biểu.
Tụi,
là những vật khóc kích thức rất nhỏ.
Sau bị quán đường chúng ta đi được.
Qua quán cách mà chúng ta để cập biểu.
Bí dụt quá,
các bạn nhìn đây là một nắm.
Ông đăng này thì khoảng 1 tế li bệnh của nha.
Ông 1 tế li bệnh của nha.
Chất biểu này,
thì khoảng 1 tế li bệnh của nha.
Vì tế thức là nhỏ.
Nó rất nhỏ.
Sau bị quán đường đi được.
có thể có thể có thể.
Tụi,
ôi tơ,
trách thức,
đúng nhỏ.
Thì ôi tơ,
bí dụt,
nhỏ,
nó rất nhỏ.
Sau bị quán cách.
Vậy,
có thể thật hà lâu.
có thể có,
nó rất nhỏ.
Em khu nhỏ.
có thể có,
nó rất nhỏ.
Vậy,
桃 sơ.
Bây giờ,
không làm sao làm sao?
桃 sơ.
Gián có幾 tui lắm, sóng quá quang lợng gì đâu thì nó có lá trời đi ở
所以singing, thấy được rồi
OK, xem, trái không lại, rồi nhớ
Tế là uối lời gó v Analytics em mặt nó đi
Vậy
Yeah
Kêu tu me nhớ thì làm b accounted ký gì thain nhé
Em g spaced má lạng trên kêu tu mẹ, figure tu mẹ, figure tu mẹ gì đâu hả?
Và không có máy nhiều xem có để xem này Ranho trên kêu tu mẹ
Mình, tôi có có mấy nhiều khoảng vida mình các hiện tạm không lưu vì đâu lại đâu
Yeah
Trát tên, tên của cách bó có, thì nó tính như tên của cách kêu tu mẹ
có thể chết nha mắt quá
ra hình tham bánh mình nhau
không nhau bánh bạn
rồi, tiếp theo, thái nọd nhau
vô thằng ngọt lại là bạn
Với đấy, có thể chết nha mắt nó
không có thể chết nha mắt nó
có bằng bây giờ, nó không khi mà nó ăn ví chuyển trên đường.
Đúng là, thì các trắng không có lần thằng.
Nó sẽ có đặt găng, đúng là, đúng là, đúng là, chí áo, chí áo, chí áo, đúng là, tròn, đúng là, thì bàn hộ, thì xức chuyển,
của của của xe điểm nhé.
Bây giờ, thì thùng là, bây giờ, một bằng như thế nào,
thì tất cả để tất cả để tất cả.
Bây giờ, bây giờ, bây giờ, bây giờ, bây giờ, bây giờ, bây giờ, bây giờ, bây giờ, bây giờ, bây giờ,
chẳng hà như là, bây giờ, bây giờ, thằng này.